this podcast and every other podcast
that I make is brought to you by our
supporters on patreon not only are they
the reason that this kind of Niche show
exists at all they also get some cool
benefits including completely ad-free
episodes early episodes unedited
episodes and the ability to submit
questions plus depending on the tier a
special shout out at the end and the
ability to play games with me so if any
of these things interest you or you just
like to support this particular show
head to patreon.com
hello everyone welcome to another
episode of video game writing 101 today
I'm joined by Danny and the sun sorry
that it's so blown out um Danny who are
you exactly and what are you doing here
I am the lead writer of Jedi Survivor
one of you to talk game riding with you
I'm super excited uh what are your
credits outside of Jedi survival like
how do you just suddenly become the lead
writer of Star Wars EA Triple A video
game
just proved just they just found me on
the street uh I worked uh I started
about 12 years ago in game writing did a
bunch of indie games did a fellowship at
the University of Texas working with
Warren Specter and from there
um worked at gearbox on an unannounced
IP and then a bunch of Borderlands stuff
and uh Tiny Tina's wonderlands and then
jump ship and uh you know
wanted to wanted to try my head at Star
Wars which has been amazing
congratulations uh I imagine
it's pretty different working on Star
Wars to working on I mean even though
Borderlands is an established IP Star
Wars is uno established IP what are some
of the unique challenges that come with
working on Star Wars
um I mean I think one of the things just
as a writer is like the weight of
expectation we've got a lot of really
incredible Star Wars stories out there
and uh we have a fan base that is always
hungry for you know new stories and so
when we were working on Survivor it's
always in the back of my mind was like
how do our characters stand up like how
engaging are we what are we doing in the
Galaxy that feels kind of new and
different
how do you balance that is that like a
team perspective or does someone that
comes through play testing
um I think part of it is you know the
respawn team was really smart to kind of
find their corner of the Galaxy they
could play in and
um as a result you know Fallen order and
Survivor to me feel like very intimate
stories in the Star Wars Universe we're
not really going after a huge Galactic
sweeps of you know the soap opera is
there to some extent but it's really a
story about Callen is his kind of earned
a family and how they kind of survive
definitely agree I feel like the
sometimes the scope of Star Wars can be
like everybody no in this galaxy
everybody and I feel like the
this Jedi franchise that you're working
on is a little more contained um but I
would love to talk about Cal because I
played both games and I feel like
um Cal initially was kind of cookie cut
a hero who serves the story and everyone
else is a little more interesting than
him
um whereas in survivor he's got some
more Edge to him so how did there's
obviously a pretty significant gap
between these two games how did you
approach Cal's journey and and uh the
kind of evolution that he goes on as a
character without losing his identity
you know I mean I think it starts with
the beginning right so um when you uh
when you start the game on Coruscant Cal
has been fighting the empire for five
years and he's largely been failing um
you know he's been doing the best he can
but um
but he's fighting a losing battle and
you know in the opening Mission he kind
of realizes that and so this game is
less about how Cal kind of honors his
Jedi past and fights against the uh
Empire who took so much of him and more
about
um how he's going to kind of survive the
this time period That's so dark in the
Galaxy right there's very little hope
and Star Wars is such a franchise about
Hope In This Moment there's almost none
of it and so you know a lot of I think
the
the challenges he faces is how you
derive hope in a galaxy that has little
to none at a time who do you put your
faith in um who do you choose to Ally
with who do you choose to fall in love
with is that a thing that you are
actively conscious of when trying to
write Cal like
how much hope does he have if that's
such an important thing to Star Wars as
a franchise
yeah I think so I mean I think one of
the things I like a lot about college
he's got a very interesting kind of not
morbid sense of humor but kind of a
darker sense of humor he's been through
so much since his childhood right
um since the Clone Wars in order 66 and
so whenever he shows a bit of optimism
it's always kind of interesting and rare
to me and I think that's why uh BD is
such a good counterbalance because BD Is
His companion Droid and he's just
um he is the it is the is the character
that helps Cal retain hope in his
darkest moments and so like the two of
them and their friendship I think is
really fun to play with I guess bd1 is
also like the co-protagonist he's there
all the time yeah he's just as much of a
character so how do you it's a great
follow-up is how do you write bd1 is
there a Style guy do you have a
character sheet do you have like a like
when you're writing dialogue is it Boop
like how do you actually write the Droid
it's definitely a Boop I mean that you
know BD is kind of like Cal's little
companion slash like best friend dog and
when we're writing scripts the line is
always boot and that's kind of like a a
rule of the writing team as we don't try
to the sound sound designers will come
later and they will interpret the kind
of like parenthetical personality or
intent so we might say like I'm afraid
in a parenthetical it's still Boop and
then the sound designers will come back
in um and I think you know um BD's kind
of sticking with these kind of
um pure emotions whether it's fear or
hope or curiosity uh help us write cow
because Cal can kind of interpret that
and then kind of expand on it I also
love how comforting he is because
sometimes I feel like that works well
with the player too like you're you're
up against something that looks enormous
and you're like oh my God am I gonna be
able to do this and then he comes with
Speedy one and I'm like that works for
me too I've also been confident
um I mean he's so cute too like did that
come organically I know Manny also
worked on uh the creation of of bd1
because I spoke to him before
um of like how how adorable he is like
there's Lego of him now like this just
little joy that everybody's just falling
in love with
I wasn't on the first game so I don't
know how they did it but I do think BD
is like one of the most cherished and
wonderful parts of like response
contribution to the Galaxy there's just
something so his curiosity is so
infectious and incredible that like even
during like the hard times on the
project as anyone on a project would
have because video games are amazingly
difficult to make like BD is one of
those like sources of Hope for all of us
that's very cute
um so directly from that question uh you
did not work on the first game but you
worked on Jedi Survivor um what is it
like coming in on a sequel
for me it was just you know an
incredible opportunity you know as I was
finishing some of my work at um gearbox
I had this kind of like short list of
like dream like projects to work on and
I played falling order right when it
came out and I think just like a lot of
fans I the characters just really
resonated for me in a way that um I
hadn't expected
um
you know I remember playing
Fallen order with my wife and when Marin
like entered the picture she just
swooned like she was like I've never
seen a female character like this in a
game and I've watched you play a lot of
games and
um so as you're kind of talking about my
career next steps you're like wow we
gotta try to get on this vehicle it's
gonna be incredible yeah how did you
actually action that was that just
telling people at respawn that you
really wanted to do it
I reached out to the narrative director
and said I'm a big fan and I'd love to
work on the game that's awesome
yeah I feel like there's a lot of Truth
in especially for writing I've done that
a million times if it's
you can't always expect opportunities to
come to you you kind of have to create
them uh like if you want to do something
you kind of have to make it happen
yeah I think it's really true I mean um
when I talk to a lot of like young
aspiring game writers and narrative
designers I tell them the same thing
which is like you can't wait for an
opportunity most jobs aren't posted like
uh you got to have all your scripts
ready and you know so it's like every
few years I'll write a spec script on a
few games I've played and enjoyed just
because you never know what happens and
I didn't do that for a falling order but
when I when I wrote my first script I'd
been thinking about it a lot like I'd
been thinking about what kind of what I
would want to do with Cal and Marin and
kind of um if I got the chance and so
when I actually uh like during the team
it was a pretty natural thing for me
that's awesome yeah like a dream come
true
um really amazing yeah
so I
um
we spoke about this slightly before we
started recording but uh I feel like
it's a common criticism at the moment of
some games writing which I understand
why it exists that uh characters could
be too chatty uh your protagonist can be
too chatty especially when they have an
ensemble
um this is something that seemingly like
doesn't come up that much in play
testing but then it seems like the
internet gets really upset which you
know is half the reason why it's theirs
play test is like I got confused
um I do not feel like that happens in
Jedi Survivor and uh as we were talking
about just just before there's a lot of
Silence at the start of the game
um where almost everybody else I think
would go for having especially because
it's Star Wars it's so easy having Cal
quip or make jokes or you know be
self-deprecating um was that intentional
restraint and how do you balance
how often you want him to see something
versus actually sitting in silence and
letting players kind of commentate
themselves
yeah I mean it's a great question I
think
um
our inner desire as writers is to kind
of
explain potentially and and really like
paint the world with with dialogue as
often as you can but like in an opening
level like horizontal there's so much
happening where this is really high
stakes
um what we're trying to do a lot very
quickly setting the scene kind of
getting players up to speed
um I always think about
how often dialogue's playing and how how
long I want a particular line of
dialogue to resonate so for example like
there's an exchange in the Coruscant
where
um
the ISB officer whose boat says you know
um level 2046
um uh seen better days and uh Bravo
replies war is expensive someone's got
to pay for it and like to me like that
exchange just kind of like that sets
what's happened in the last decade uh
for people in the undercity and if you
have dialogue that follows right after
that or too much like that that those
lines won't resonate and the player
won't really think about them and you
know sometimes dialogue stacks and gains
meeting as you add more and more but
other times restraint and taking lines
away and creating that kind of um that
space for something to resonate for the
player to really chew over it I think is
really effective so was that how that
scene looked at the start or was it
edited back oh no it's all absolutely
not I mean we it's a lot of iteration
and revision I think you know like any
anyone's first pass or 10 first 10
passes on the script are Shock full of
dialogue as you're trying to really
figure out what you want to say and then
you know slowly over time you refine it
and then you get the perfect
professional recording in um and then
before pickups you really go okay wow
like these lines are hitting on their
own you get a bit of confidence and from
that you can take away and take away
until just like the best stuff's left
yeah and then I know this is different
for every Studio but as you work with
other teams like you work with audio
work with level design or whoever else
does that have a huge impact on the
dialogue that stays like maybe you'll
have a line added in or removed based on
something level design did for example
is that is that like a part of the
process for you oh yeah all the time I
mean you know like to take Coruscant um
either narrative designer or an artist
recommended that a probe Droid
um appears near the very beginning of
the level and that wasn't originally
part of it
um the probe Droid moment later is when
uh comes down by the bridge and kind of
scans what you will soon find out is
like the briefcase that contains Cal
lightsaber and that was the Droid moment
but someone recommended putting that in
earlier because it's creepy because now
you get this kind of impression of the
Empire and the Senators kind of watching
your every move and like once you have
that visual representation presentation
you can kind of peel some of the
dialogue back and take some some stuff
out that was trying to convey that
emotion because the visual I think is
stronger in that case it's also like you
said I definitely agree that it's hard
not to overwrite things
um or want to put dialogue for color and
everything but I think it's also kind of
nice when players can feel like they've
figured something out on their own uh
rather than having a character just tell
them like if you can convey the plot
which I think you guys did I don't want
to well I could spoil the first level
Coruscant in general is is like sort of
a mini Heist that has some twists and
tones in it which happens so fast
um then I didn't feel like the
characters were taking me along for a
ride I felt like I was part of it and I
think it some of that does come from not
explaining to me or over explaining the
stakes or who everyone is at every
single step of the way
um and I also think this is a spoiler
the choice to have people die so fast
was a very interesting one to me uh are
we uh are we not talking spoilers I mean
I think we are it's been a month we're
okay yeah go ahead
yeah yeah
spoilers I can put a spoiler want to get
the start actually it's just so people
know
um you know I mean I think with the
first part of the question
um you know that's a really tricky
opening to write you're introducing five
new characters to the player
um the stakes aren't what they seem
s you're we're kind of both putting the
player in the the player as Cal is kind
of have to think to catch up with Cal
because it's the heist is a ruse right
um and that's really challenging
um to pull off and again I think that's
why we felt less less was more in this
case because we didn't want to tip our
hand we wanted players to kind of Intuit
from how this crew was talking well
maybe I didn't realize it at first
because I was so blown away by looking
at the environments and then the second
time I played through the opening I was
like oh they do mention it like I just
yeah totally guarded it's very guarded
you know and also we're trying to do
um triple Duty there because we want you
to care about these characters but
they're helmeted which makes it very
tough because you're really just sharing
their process of voices but we have so
little time with this crew that we want
everything
um to kind of have meaning and so gabs
is definitely one of my favorite
characters of The Heist crew it's like
you can you learned really early on it's
just kind of the schemer it's just a
little bit in it for the credits but you
have to do it on that in such a tight
tight room so really really challenging
did you decide to kill them all why
could they not have lived
uh you know I think
um they kind of stand as Cal's surrogate
family now that the mantisco uh has kind
of went their separate ways after the
events have fallen order and
um you know he
calls so much of Cal story's finding
family and and holding on to family
because he never has really had it you
know
um and uh yeah it was sad for me too I
think I mean I loved those characters I
thought the corusc crew was really cool
I would love to do a whole thing with
just them but uh you know unfortunately
uh these are dark times and uh I guess
it does very quickly set up that they
are that it's it's a dark time not
everything the sunshine and rainbows
yeah
um so you mentioned a narrative designer
um you just said that phrase and I
always want to ask means a different
thing at every Studio
at respawn what is a narrative designer
what do they do
narrative designers are
Mission designers that work really
closely at the writers and level
designers and the rest of our kind of
small level teams and they do
um all of the scripting for our
companion characters like Bowden Marin
they do all the bo implementation
um they really have an eye towards and
help us as writers understand the
opportunities in any given level how
something will be implemented if there's
something that a writer isn't thinking
about in terms of the difficulty of
implementing dialogue or um or anything
else that has to do with the kind of
story delivery so your narrative
designers are the ones putting the
dialogue in engine
yep okay yeah because I know that's
different depending on the studio as
well
um some of them seem to be like very
systems based like at some studios that
the people who make sure that dialogue
doesn't overlap uh they work more
closely with level design than writers
sometimes so it's just such an
interesting term that I think is like
more Studios have them now but it still
tends to mean a different thing some
studios don't have writers they just
have narrative designers yeah very true
yeah I know I think I'm obsidian is like
that yeah I'm thankful for the the
having the two different kind of
um roles because I think when you cross
into more of the design mindset
um you have a certain lens of how you
tell the story which is very different
from I think if you're approaching
things mostly from kind of a writing
entertainment point of view and it's
it's a nice kind of um bit of friction
when you know a writer goes to a
narrative designer says like I've got
this idea on the narrative design it's
like well how are we going to pull it
off and I think that kind of that that
dialogue creates really interesting
moments it's probably also pretty
important for scope like I think if
you're just going straight from writing
something you can unintentionally let
this has happened to me where I pitch
something and not known how expensive it
is and having narrative design it'll be
like we probably can't do that very
quickly be like that might be slightly
too expensive uh you can't just get in
game I want you to hand an object to
another NPC no no no yeah definitely not
happening
um yeah sorry just that's a very
technical question but an interesting
one to ask so outside of that what is
your actual process for for writing on a
game like this respawn
um do the writers start first like who
literally how how did you stop the
narrative for this game what what's the
process
um well I joined a few uh a little bit
after pre-production had started so I
can't speak to the origins completely
but I mean story is obviously a really
integral part of um the Jedi franchise
and so we work with uh creative director
Stig
um our narrative director
um and then LucasArts as we're kind of
um breaking story and characters and
then simultaneously were also kind of
laying the foundation for like the
general narrative flow of the game which
helps inform level design and kind of
our art sets and everything so but I
think you know my experience at respawn
is it's been a very organic kind of
process of like teams kind of working
kind of coinciding and working together
um as we replying the story what's it
like to work with lucasots I don't know
how much he could say but no that that
is not a thing that a lot of Studios do
in terms of like working on a franchise
that somebody else owns uh like Star
Wars so what does that relationship like
I mean I I've had a great time with the
Olympus Arts I think um it's been really
fascinating seeing
um the franchise and kind of how Lucas
starts talking about the franchise and
um you know we have um sync meetings and
they're just kind of really wonderful
exchanges of ideas and I think you know
for me coming from a place of being a
Star Wars fan but I hadn't like read all
the novels and comic books um there's
just a really incredible amount of like
um things I didn't know about Star Wars
that I learned over the course of of the
project which was really helpful
that's cool like in terms of actually
writing for Star Wars what are you
starting with you just
read a bunch of stuff to people research
for you like how do you actually dive
into the universe for
being the lead writer on a game
yeah I mean there's you know there's
plenty out there and it's all really
fascinating so much you know when I
first started yeah when I first started
uh on the team I read some novels uh in
some comic books and watched all the TV
shows and movies
um and I think also just playing Fallen
order was really instructive to me
because I think it was a really well
researched game that really again chose
some sections of the IP that I wasn't as
familiar with like being quite serious
as an example and
um you know so for Survivor there was
such a really good foundation from
Fallen order on kind of what what the
identity of um the games were about and
so for me it was a relatively seamless
thing I'm sure there was a lot of heavy
lifting and hard work yeah and research
and stuff that came before that but by
the time I joined the project
um I felt like I had a really good
understanding of kind of what new space
is the the game is gonna take place in
and kind of the information I needed to
to figure out the right decisions for
characters that's great love that uh in
terms of new characters and and the
exist and characters that obviously
repeat in um Survivor I was talking
about this while playing through it um
super curious how you approached
the amount of new players who might play
Survivor who didn't play full and Order
and the clear importance of these
characters to cow because obviously I
can't remove my own memory of playing
Fallen order so I was like I wonder if
new players how they take the
introduction or the reintroduction to
some of these characters and how
important they are is it confusing how
do you balance that like things that are
clearly important in the first game for
anyone playing the sequel but the fact
that you might have people playing
Survivor who didn't charge Fallen order
yeah it's I mean it's really tough it's
always tough to understand kind of what
I mean even for people who played
falling order the game came out you know
many many years ago and um I mean I will
say just a shout out to like that
opening kind of like story recap I
thought was absolutely beautiful when I
first saw that I was like oh well this
is doing a lot of the work for us like
um I think you get a lot of kind of just
the tone and the understanding of kind
of Cal's basic relationship to calamari
in Greece from that so that was very
helpful I think you know beyond that
there's information like I think one of
the challenges for game writers always
understanding what to include and what
not to include yeah um or where to
include certain information and and
where to put other information right and
I think one of the values and the the
joys of game writing is you have
cinematics and you have grid path levels
and then you have all of these other
wonderful Avenues where you can kind of
tell more about characters so if you
might not have remembered so much of the
relationship between Seer and Cal as an
example you can talk in serious base and
kind of find more more about that
relationship so there are avenues for
players that are interested to kind of
peek back into the relationships from
Jedi fall in order
yeah I definitely agree that the opening
uh like recap was incredible and I
imagine pretty hard to make I feel like
whoever made that
stuff is way harder than it seems a lot
of the time
um but in terms of adding in new
characters I've forgotten the
character's name
um the frog that everyone's losing their
minds about yes would you expect that
because I also loved him immediately I
love that voice actor and he's what he's
like maybe an hour and a half in and
he's just so so lovable um yeah did you
expect the internet to to blow up about
toggle lovable is an interesting word to
use
um
uh I think it could have gone either way
um and for some people maybe it did I
you know characters like turtle are so
fun to write because they're just
instigators and like every story needs
instigators and and literally he's the
instigator of this story because he's
been trying to find something for Ravis
one of the the villains he face and um
you know I read a lot of turtle a lot of
the Cantina stuff as well and I think
maybe part of that was just from my
experience writing for the Borderlands
franchise which contains innumerable
amount of zany characters
um but I think some of the the things
kind of I learned from working in
Borderlands was even a character like
carrigal who's basically a cartoon
character um has to have something
underpinning them or they kind of seem
flat and Hollow and so um there's for
people who wish to talk to Turbo more
than once
um as you kind of delve deeper into uh
our insane Frog's character there's just
some there's some fun kind of twists and
turns and
his emotional state I loved him his
crushing loneliness
um it also helps that the voice actor is
like absolutely incredible and has that
kind of nuance of comedic timing I mean
it's really uh we were helped a lot we
had a great cast all told
um but uh Richard who played turtle was
just uh yeah knocked out of the park but
did you expect people to freak out about
Tuggle the way they have
I knew they would freak out but again
how would they freak out yeah absolute
hate absolute love Yeah I think that's
comedic characters are just tough you
just never know you never know if a
character is going to hit or feel
grading to players I'm delighted I think
really weird and I think that's you know
it's like there's a lot of sci-fi
franchises out there uh there's not a
lot of of
Worlds that are like Star Wars where you
can have like Ultra serious dramatic
characters and then like a scheming frog
who's always trying to like build people
at a Cantina and I I like the the
breadth of tone there it's really it's
really fun to work in yeah and it's it's
also do you find it to be restricting
like I feel like in my head Jedi
Survivor and I would say like Rogue one
and andol of all the modern Star Wars
for me and and full and Order
um feel the most Star Wars like I'm I
could elaborate on that but I won't
it'll take too long but they feel very
Star Wars I think Jedi survive has done
such a good job of like having me
actually feel like I'm walking through
any of the pre-existing movies
um is that tone restrictive for you to
play around in or do you feel like it's
very freeing
I think it's very freeing I mean I think
um you know
Star Wars you know growing up on like
watching the original trilogy like it's
it's such a
dark story to like uh to go through
because I think for me Star Wars is like
about it's about Hope and how hope
survives over Generations
um which is like if there's like one
thing I think entertainment like does
that's really positive it's like to
remind us of things that came before
trials and tribulations and to give us
some some small semblance that things
can get better and that um the fight can
go on
um but and that's really like a heavy
kind of theme right and so like I feel
like it's it'd be really hard to pull it
off across one story let alone hundreds
if you didn't have the turtles of the
world if you didn't have these strange
weird bits of the Galaxy that um you
know that kind of give you not only some
comic relief but also just the stakes
kind of
um to me at least become greater when
you have like weird comedic characters
alongside like characters who are
fighting fighting for their very lives
yeah I guess you something to fight for
too like if you have characters who are
positive you feel like you have to fight
for their positivity to stay so not
everything's all gloomy and
I was just happy to see him I'd totally
fight for toggle yeah I loved him do you
have a favorite character in the uh
energetic Survivor I guess to narrow it
down I can't choose I think
um one of the characters I think
um really resonated for me and um and
was a lot of fun to write that I hadn't
seen
quite as often in Star Wars as the
character Moran who's kind of a washed
up
um Trader who finds his way to The
Cantina and he's cynical and Surly and
contains absolutely no hope whatsoever
and um looks at the rest of
um the fellow patrons of the Cantina
with like almost just like Universal
disgust and I think that character and
the course of his story was just kind of
something a little different that I I
hadn't seen so often so it was really
fun to kind of unpack this character
who's felt like his life was basically
over and that he had missed Ever every
opportunity in his life and there was
nothing around the corner to look
forward to and if you if you play his
story and you
talk with him all the way to the end
there's kind of some some fun reveals
that I think um felt kind of gratified
uh I can answer that question by the
number of gray hairs
this is a podcast which is say a lot of
characters
it does seem like a pretty significant
amount do you know how much dialogue he
recorded I I can't imagine you know the
lines off my heart either
it's tons I mean you know even when you
just think about like the
um Cantina uh Pages that's what I was
thinking about hundreds and hundreds of
pages across
um we have what we call macro states
which are like the five general kind of
um big story beats
um that the Cantina and kind of its
patrons turn turn through and then we
have substates which are like now we
really get into the weeds here so it's
which are like the smaller tonal shifts
from plot point to plot point and
across macro States and sub States it's
like
25 or 30 which means every time you
stream back in there you can talk to a
character and get more dialogue and
that's
um that's irrespective of then other
ways that we add dialogue based on
different uh player progressions so it's
it's a ton of work um
right like the people don't actually
have a lot of games on yeah absolutely
yeah so much of it's optional
um but again you know that's you know
our goal is to create a stores Cantina
like it's got to be populated with a
wide variety of strange lovable hateable
characters who have something to say not
only about Cal's story but about just
what's happening on Kobo and whatnot and
um that's part of the part of the job is
you write a lot of stuff that you don't
know players will ever engage with but I
think from what I've seen on the
reaction
um online it's like
when you hit a line of dialogue and
someone like it resonated for someone
and it was like buried for conversations
deep into a sub State and they like
write you and they're like I really love
this like it does kind of feel worth it
uh even though it was a lot of work was
that a thing you had to fight for at all
like making sure that the Cantina was
heavily populated with so many lines of
dialogue where you know I feel like
making AAA games is just a bunch of give
and take for several years between
different facets like was that something
that everyone was unified on from the
start
yeah I think the team wanted to nail can
Star Wars Cantina I mean I think that
was just a fantasy that like I mean a
lot of resources were put into that
because it's such a powerful fantasy in
the Star Wars universe and
um up for our part on the narrative side
um we couldn't
sparsely populate that with a few
characters and call it a day like I
think we wanted the player to feel
both The Emptiness of the Cantina when
you first arrive on Kobo it starts to
fill up slowly both based on like the
main plot but also recruiting um
different characters and then it starts
to empty again based on uh the Empire's
growing presence and I think having that
Cadence of the rise and fall the Cantina
was definitely resource intensive but I
think really worth it like for players
who played through the end game and then
they've talked to everyone in the
Cantina like there's some I think some
of the best writing honestly in the game
is like the last few characters who
remain in the Cantina after everyone
else has left it's crazy because the
percentage of players who've done that
has to be so low like what are the
current stats of finishing at least like
10 I think is currently the finishing
rate for most video games and like the
importance of all of that and how rarely
people see it is like something I try
not to think about
yeah I mean it is so crushing if you
think about it too much but I think the
other way it also makes it special about
it
what's especially and also like um the
community that you carry from one game
to the other it's like worth its weight
in gold and like that you you know as a
game ready you can provide this meaning
and this little extra bit of time for
players to spend time with characters
that they've grown attached to
um is really rewarding yeah and those
players are the ones on Reddit talking
about I can't believe this character did
this I would have you and I think like
from from game to game that kind of that
Community is really valuable to to
Foster how much time do you actually
spend like watching people's reactions
watching Let's Plays with streams or
reading stuff on Reddit when the game
came out because I feel like working on
Star Wars is a lot of pressure
look I was really excited when the
critical Olympian reaction was very
positive
um
it was really rewarding I mean look
um you know like you spend years of your
life on a project like you don't know
how it's gonna turn out games are
difficult the most difficult thing in a
game is telling a story in my opinion
because there's so many aspects of like
um of Storytelling that like a game
reader just doesn't really have access
to like pacing as an example right and
so
um when when you when you actually
you know finish a game on the depth side
and it goes out like you and it's
positive like I I'm ravenous I love
seeing people talk about the ending and
debating over like character choices and
I love just the silly Let's Plays of
people fooling around or talking to
turtle and getting told like go wake out
like I just think that stuff's puffy I
mean why do we write if not to entertain
people and so I want to I want to see
that entertainment yeah absolutely yeah
I can't imagine not to be fair I can't
imagine not engaging with it that would
be a little bit strange but it is an
interesting thing that I think I didn't
understand before I started working in
Dev
and I don't know if this applies to
everybody but it definitely doesn't mean
it sounds like it might for you is that
while working on something I lose
concept of if it's good or not
um I had that with Ragnarok uh that I
was like I think it it is I'm pretty
sure but I don't know because you see
something in so many iterations and
you're you're looking at it as a
technical thing of like are all the
parts where they're supposed to be
rather than as a game anymore
um so when it came out and people liked
it I was like oh thank God
the game hundreds of times like across
every version of it when we had Robo
voice and we had a you know I mean and
you just it's I think it's really hard
to get clarity on what you're what
you're building that's why you do play
testing and I think that really helps to
some extent
um you know it's
it's hard to play something for the 20th
time and still like it even if it's
written perfectly and I think one of the
things that's
um really challenging for us as like a
narrative team is
um not changing things for the sake of
us as devs wanting to hear something new
and different
um and so I'll I'll definitely Spark
from time to time with uh you know given
lines where I'm like I know we're tired
of this line it's a good line that's
really interesting I hadn't thought of
that before if you can be like is that
lying bad because they've heard it a
hundred times
hmm that's it's really tough I mean I
think a lot of I don't know if this has
been your experience but my experience
as game writers also that like half of
the job is like advocacy like advocacy
across like gaining resources for
storytelling but then also kind of um
defending your work and kind of
um knowing that a voice delivered a lot
of dialogue delivered in Robo voice will
sound good in a professional actor gets
a hold of it I swear you know yeah I
think that's I think it's something you
kind of like hopefully learn over time
and um you have a good enough kind of
radar to understand like what's what's
going to kind of play as you get uh more
more resources and and you know actors
and stuff on it yeah so to talk about
actors and Robo voice I guess um for
anyone who doesn't know Robo voice is
generally like you'll have robots Regal
lines before you hire an actual actor we
sometimes have people in the studio
uh atreus was voiced by a female Dev for
a long time which is always really fun
because they're not actors oh yeah
um what is your costing process like
like you're costing for a character like
struggle
uh I mean any of the huge band of
characters that you have
uh do you write with actors in mind
obviously you get to do that with with
cat with Cameron um but otherwise you
know is it something that you send out a
sheet for some of them or some of them
you cast in your head beforehand like
how much flexibility is that when you're
actually writing these characters
yeah we you know we have our casting
sheets and they often have a section
where uh we'll reference either actors
or characters from popular media kind of
just to give the um anyone reading kind
of a general sense like tonally and kind
of um you know characterize what we're
going for
um and then from there you know we we
it's a pretty wonderful process of
hearing 20 to 50 you know
um takes on a character
um and you know sometimes it just fits
like in the opening lines and an actor
is just kind of like gleaned what what
you were hoping for and just kind of
nails it um Moran as an example
um we knew as we started writing Moran
I'd worked with John Michael Tatum who's
the actor who plays Moran on Borderlands
franchise he plays uh certain animal
walk and as we started writing Miranda I
I knew John Michael Tatum just like was
the person for it I'd worked with him
enough I saw kind of how he can deliver
Nuance of a cynical kind of like tone
and so that was like that was a
character like if he's available we're
gonna hire him um we definitely um you
know but that's it differs based on
auditions and whatnot we cast a pretty
wide map okay
do you ever have sorry I'm so sick my
voice is such a mess
um do you ever have somebody
do something you completely didn't
expect and then you kind of rewrite
parts of the character based on really
liking an audition that was not at all
what you had in your head
um less so for auditions and more so for
like when we when we select an actor and
we you know once they've been cast and
we've kind of had our first session with
them I mean I think you know if you're
not learning a lot from uh about your
characters from an actor like you're not
doing your job as a writer because I
think you know so much of the value of
whether you're in performance capture
shoots or whether you're in the vo Booth
is listening to how someone with a
different perspective takes your
character and kind of brings them to to
that performance and
so much of the fun like the best part
for me being a good burger is absolutely
working with the actors because they
just
um they see things differently you know
um my dad's uh professor and he um and
my mom ran a independent theater when I
was a kid and so I spent a lot of time
like a community theater just listening
to the actors rehearse and and whatnot
and I think
um you know a line can can shift like
just based on the inflection like a
single award and it's kind of magical
and in game writing where you have such
confined spaces um to some extent like
you're really looking for those moments
where an actor can kind of say something
just slightly different and now it's not
a cliche line it's a line that has a
meaning and I think that's that's
something I I always kind of um Advocate
when we're working with actors is to
really listen to them because they're
really smart yeah I mean it's their job
to like take your character and know
them more intimately than even you do
it's so cool uh do you I know that this
doesn't happen for every Studio do you
on the writing Team all get to like join
for the mocap days or be in the vo booth
uh the for the mocap performance capture
stuff it was Aaron uh Contreras who was
the narrative director and then me on on
sad
um there's a lot of people on those
performance capture suits and uh it's
just a lot going on and I mean they're
really fun but um you need like tight
turnarounds on revisions and uh you know
Aaron and I would talk to the actors and
the directors and kind of have to
repitch moments and kind of explain the
context because you know they're they're
reporting a lot of the stuff like out of
a little in your order
across years
um which is you know you get good at
kind of um selling the story helping
like quickly Orient
um an actor to kind of their motivation
which is really really fun and then
you're taking the feedback on set which
is like um I think maybe outside looking
in some writers might balk at that but
like it's a really wonderful part of the
process because like it's very rigorous
and
if an actor doesn't believe the lines
they're about to deliver like it won't
turn out well and so you either have to
advocate for and like get them in the
headspace of like why you know a scene
should work a certain way or you can
kind of shift and rewrite the scene a
bit too to kind of better fit how they
view the character and I think both are
really valid I'm on the vo side yeah we
have um our writers often are parts of
the vo sessions depending on how busy
they are but it's really valuable again
just to hear an actor kind of
um go through lines and how they kind of
evolve and how they are we often
re-record the first 20 lines of a
session just because the actor has now
been warmed up and yeah they've gotten
into the character a bit more and I
think this is useful for uh for writers
to see too that's so cool because yeah
no not every Studio does that for that
right this was it the same in gearbox
yeah but gearbox was like when I first
joined gearbox I was the video director
for Minecraft
so it's like I was just working with our
audio engineer and uh at our actors so I
was pretty used to that and so we would
kind of and then another writer would
join and basically be like skip Wrangler
and so we kind of um did that gearboxes
change a lot since then and they have a
wonderful video director and and it's a
bit um more kind of ordered like that
but that's kind of where I I kind of
like cut you know that's the whole
podcast before I started that makes it
exactly
um so I'm going to ask you some super
broad questions now
um in terms of video game writing in
general not just about working on Jedi
Survivor what's your favorite part of
the job
I think the moments where
design art and writing come together uh
in a game are magical and they're so
difficult to pull off because every
discipline is looking for something
different and
um so you know
as I mentioned like if I'm advocating
for a moment in a game and then it comes
through you can feel it I think in most
of the best games or the games that
resonate with me everything's working in
tandem so I always disparate elements
kind of coming together in in this kind
of wonderful moment that uh that I think
you can't it's hard to replicate across
like linear media because like you're
part of the story like the story is kind
of like allowing you to step into the
role of a character and um and they're
they're hard to pull off because games
are hard to make there's so many people
it's just so many so many people so many
people yeah I guess I will say one thing
that I've found
uniquely very magical
for my time at Santa Monica Studio is um
when multiple disciplines are
unanimously excited about something
everyone's like this is really cool we
can't wait to do this and then they
bounce an idea back to you and then you
bounce an idea forward and everyone's
really excited like I don't know that I
felt that way about anything in my life
ever when it's hundreds of people being
like this is awesome let's do it like
that's so so so cool and probably pretty
unique to games because of the amount of
just moving parts that are required to
make a video game
when you're playing a game that like
really resonates for you can you like
sense those moments where you feel like
on the other side the team kind of all
came together I think I can now I don't
think I could before I uh started
working in Dev uh now I'll be like oh I
bet you they're all stoked about that
whereas beforehand
yeah you don't you don't think about it
you're just like this is cool for me you
don't think about the the bigger picture
of all the people who worked on it so
yeah I would say now I definitely can
and especially certain things you're
like oh they definitely have to fight
for that like oh that would have been so
expensive because I had so little
concept of scope even working in games
media before I started working in Dev of
like just how expensive and difficult
some things are
um like Jedi Survivor has a bunch of
quadrupeds
like that's hot I know now that's really
hard whereas before I'd be like why
doesn't the horse walk right and now I'm
like it's so difficult to animate and so
expensive to animate anything that works
on full likes can everything float like
that's a lot cheaper uh there's a lot of
stuff like that we've got this pitch
it's a horse but it's floating in air
everything floats here that's the best
way to get it in
question
what is the most challenging thing about
being a games writer or your least
favorite
wow how long do we have um
I mean I think it's the converse to kind
of the appreciation of those moments
that come together which is to say
um you know there's people play games
from such vastly different reasons like
you know I'm really fortunate
um
you know to to be on a franchise where
story is so important
um but even that being said like uh
there are times where players want to
explore and uh maybe the designers you
know want to give players you know a
sneak peek into what other things they
could be doing and I think
um
trying to maintain a sense of tone and
character with the understanding that
like we have players who are going to
just
be lying to the story and experience
that in kind of the way the way it would
be naturally paced um and then we have
other players who are going to go
explore Kobo and um
as a gamer they're wrapping your head
around and letting go of some of that
control I think it can be scary at first
um
because it comes with such a like
narrative cost which is to say like a
longer a player is away from the main
story the less clear they have over the
characters and where they're at
emotionally and so you really have to be
careful about you know how you
reintroduce a player to a character or a
moment um understanding that they might
have been gone for a while and I think
that's really challenging I guess
letting players have agency even if it
means you feel like the story might take
a hit that's definitely a challenge
yeah so that's why yeah I think yeah
holistically kind of um you know we're
telling a character-based story in
Survivor but we're also building a new
world with Kobo and we're also providing
some really interesting information on
the high Republic and kind of exploring
that a little bit and so I think you
know you kind of have to step back in
the game writer and and go if our
characters are strong enough people will
follow us to the end and then otherwise
like what other kinds of fun experiences
can we give players that might have
nothing to do with like our Pure story
or narratives
wish more people knew about video game
writing that they maybe don't
you know I think we've we've talked
about it a bit which is to say
um you know it's so hard to tell a story
in games that if you play a game and the
characters resonate with you in any way
like it's huge clinically a miracle yeah
yeah you know I think it's um
you know it's it's useful for whether
you're like watching a TV show or
reading a novel I think it's useful to
step into the mind
um of the the developers the creators
and kind of understand how challenging
it can be to give someone an experience
you know it's a lot of things that come
together and hopefully they come
together well and I think
um you know uh
with some of that knowledge of
quadrupeds are hard
for me as a gamer like once I started
understanding more about how games are
put together I think it gave me a
greater kind of not only just like
appreciation for a game I was really
enjoying but also it kind of helped me
refocus on the things that matter in a
game like you know I'm playing Zelda
right now and every once in a while like
a tree will pop into the background but
I don't care because like it's a
beautiful game and the music and it's
just such a fun colorful world that like
some of the small technical aspects of
that like they're just not that
important that's like I don't really
think about them I just have this
wonderful beautiful pure experience and
I think you know games are like
wonderfully complex and uh when you find
moments of joy in them I think uh you
should celebrate them there's a lot of
interesting stuff
that I also wouldn't have realized
before working in Dev like
like you said your characters have uh
helmets on at the start of the game
it is so much more difficult
to have people care about characters
when you can't see their faces
so much more
um like to an incredible degree that I'm
I'm very curious about uh Diablo 4
coming out this week about how they
approach their storytelling when for the
most part outside of cutscenes the
characters are very small and you can't
see their faces it makes
video game storytelling really hard if
you're you know platforming you're not
looking at the person right next to you
who's delivering information you often
just tune it out as noise
um and that's the thing that you know
you wouldn't pay attention to unless
you're the person who's trying to make
sure people pay attention a lot of
really interesting challenges that you
have to like fight against human
psychology for sometimes which is I
really didn't realize how much of
empathy comes from looking at somebody's
face uh even if they're a video game
character and it's such a huge thing the
way they look when they say something
the way they stand when they say
something and the fact that sometimes
you have to be like okay you can run
away if you want I have no say in this
is is very scary and very hard
yeah no absolutely I mean like um you
know our narrative designers uh went to
Great Lengths to make our characters
come alive in the Cantina as an example
and like on our side those writers we're
kind of talking through the dialogue and
we the the constraints in US is you have
three or four back and forth before you
think the player will probably wander
away and so you really have to grab
someone early and then you know even if
you can see their their face in the
Cantina
um are they gesturing appropriately will
a Jester kind of turn I've definitely
played games where like the gestures of
an NPC like I can't focus on the
dialogue because the gestures didn't
match or were kind of different and so
again it's like yeah the and you only
get so many gestures for characters in a
game because it could happen to me I
voice a character in cyberpunk
and the character animation versus what
I say are so different that when I saw
it I was like oh oh then they don't
match at all and from what I thought it
would be in my head uh which makes it
like I can't watch it always like oh
this is so obvious it's really tough
um yeah I mean you know animation is
definitely one of those
um under discussed uh absolutely crucial
elements
and generate everything
it's finite and uh it's so valuable and
uh the right gesture versus the wrong
gesture can sell a conversation as as
easily or as difficult as a voice actor
yeah
um so for anyone who would like to have
your job which I'm sure is quite a few
people you got to be the lead writer on
a Star Wars game that's awesome uh not
that that I'm going to encourage people
to steal your job specifically
um you know I
after I got my job at gearbox I started
thinking about like what I had done
because I did a very quick pivot like I
wanted to be a novelist in my 20s and um
then uh uh some things happened uh a
tsunami uh and I came back to the States
and kind of had to read my evaluate my
career and what I did that I think was
like a literal stuff on me yeah so I was
uh I was in um Japan in 2011 during the
tsunami and I had this like novelist
dream job I was going to teach
um English at a Japanese high school for
like 15 hours a week and make really
good money and I was gonna like use that
to kind of write my um my first novel
and I had a girlfriend at the time and
then the tsunami hit and we decided to
leave to spend all my life savings
um getting getting back to the States uh
relationship ended and you know like my
my game register story was I like um
fished out like our Super Nintendo from
uh our our closet and played like uh
Legend of Zelda uh Link to the Past
Chrono Trigger and Final Fantasy four
and six
um over this like kind of sad few weeks
of my life and I was like well I always
had this dream of
um being a novelist first and then maybe
getting into game writing is like uh oh
an established fantasy novelist like you
know takes his crack at it and um I just
like pivoted immediately and the things
I did that I think um they're even
better tools to do nowadays is I like
took it seriously not across just game
writing but like I read like art
composition books I learned basic coding
I read a bunch of dunk design books and
I think that really helped me like very
quickly start to Intuit some of the
things that that almost you can't learn
until you become a developer
um
um and so when I started writing game
scripts and applying for jobs I think my
scripts had a bit more of that sense of
the cost of a thing and like how you
would Implement a thing and I think that
helped me
um like I was applying for a Telltale
job way back in the day and ended up
going gearbox instead but like I made my
own Walking Dead uh script in unity with
a wonderful plug-in I mean it was very
bootlegging it was like you know but
like you know I photoshopped uh The
Walking Dead characters and like did a
little mini like playable uh Choice
based script I think um
you know I think nowadays is even like
more amazing tools that to create a
nicer product so I think you know
anytime as a gamer you can show people
your your Dev knowledge your Dev skills
or you can kind of at least show that
you're thinking about other disciplines
and how they would work with you I think
that could be really useful yeah I mean
there's always a constant and I'm sure
I've said this on this exact show before
sorry to anybody who's listened to
multiple episodes
um
I think so the way that I got myself was
I was obviously came to me for a really
long time but then I decided that I
wanted to work in Dev so I just did game
jams
um I don't think
people actually fall into this job
unless they're already in Dev it's a lot
of it is like building a plan for
exactly what you want to do having the
realization is half the battle but I was
like I know I want to do this so I did
as many game jams as I could to get an
understanding of working with teams and
how different creative disciplines work
together and what your what Your Service
actually is as a game writer and how you
work with a with a programmer a level
designer or whatever
um to also build up a portfolio which I
also submitted before I got my job as
well as like I wrote short stories and
screenplays and mock game scripts for
games I liked which sounds like you did
the same thing just so that sure when I
eventually felt like I was ready for the
opportunity that I had stuff to submit
um so really a lot of it I think is you
know figure out what you want to do and
and literally map out the steps to get
there all the skills you think you would
need and apply those
yeah I think you know the other thing is
just and like
games are still part of the
entertainment industry which means
they're still incredibly difficult to
break in um and I think
um you have to try a lot of different
paths like I got I did a bunch of Indie
Games first and then I got a fellowship
and then I got a triple a job from that
and um it was a lot of years of
rejection for sure a lot of
um resumes sent uh and you know no kind
of response and I think um
it's a bit of like any entertainment
industry it's a bit of um persistence
but also a bit of luck and I think it's
like important to acknowledge that it's
like you increase your odds of
potentially breaking in just the more
you apply the more people you meet and
you know I think one thing just on top
of that is
um
game devs are pretty approachable like
we couldn't like email or send a
LinkedIn to like some famous
screenwriter whose movie you liked but
you kind of you can do that with games
that's like you can reach out to Dad's
on social media on LinkedIn and whatnot
and most of the time we will definitely
respond I agree I actually think most
people would help you
yeah and if you know if you approach it
um with kind of a level of like respect
for people's time and you kind of have
to ask questions that are like really
geared towards like the person you're
reaching out to I think I think you can
get a really good reaction I I respond
to a lot of uh LinkedIn messages and
Twitter and whatnot just because I
remember what it was like when I was
starting out and I was like am I ever
gonna make my living as a game writer
like wow like this is an impossible
thing like um and I had some debts that
that responded to me very early on and
really kind of gave me you know just
kind of the sense of like oh I could I
could be part of this someday yeah
definitely I uh again before I I got my
current job I had asked friends who I
knew who worked in the industry if I
could sit in their writer's rooms
um just to see what they do which is all
NDA I don't want to talk about any of it
but I did that for I think three
separate uh game studios where I was
just like can I like just be uh bring
your wannabe Dev to work and they all
said yes every person I all said yes
which is very cool yeah you're right the
industry is really welcoming um across
the board yeah
yeah I think you have to you have to be
hungry and don't be afraid to ask like
the worst thing is someone tells you no
but the best thing is someone goes sure
come into our writer's room yeah do you
want a job like a kid girl either
direction definitely ask like you said
uh think it's awesome that how you got
involved in respawn is in part just
telling somebody you wanted to
that's such an important thing um yeah
so I won't take up any more any much
more your time uh where can people find
it oh I'm on all the all the social
medias I started writing some articles
on sub stack about game writing and I'm
around you know is there a a place we
can send people
uh yeah Twitter and sub stack I'm most
active on
um
I could literally
Danny home and and I think it was
her at Danny underscore home and those
are the ones yeah well I'll leave a link
in the description um but otherwise
thank you so much for joining me
congratulations on making a very fun
game uh that yeah like you said just had
a bunch of wonderful cost of characters
that people do seem to have really
fallen in love with so you nailed it
thank you I appreciate it awesome and I
will see you guys next time bye
[Music]
thank you